Furthermore, we wouldn't expect those bindings to remain true across every
single invocation of this function.
If all of this seems completely obvious to you,
then you're in a great position for understanding the parameter this.
Because in JavaScript,
the keyword this behaves like a parameter in most of the important ways.
The intuitions that you've built up around how to pass values into a function
and how they'll get bound to the arguments being passed in at call time,
all those same intuitions will hold true for the parameter this.
So let's keep track of the output that we're expecting to see by putting it
in a code comment here to the right of the line they created.
We're ready to investigate what would happen if our function referred to
the parameter this inside the function body.
If we pass this as an additional input parameter at the beginning of
the logging function call, in this case, what should we expect to be logged and
bound to the parameter this while the fn function is running?
Go ahead and write out your answer.